-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
This is it. You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, this is exciting.
The 2022 NFL season
kicked off tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right now, our viewers are like,
"Am I really drunk
or does Fallon have a beard?"
Oh, it was great to have
football on TV again.
I haven't seen that
many slow-motion replays
since Harry Styles
sat next to Chris Pine.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I really...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, tonight's game was between
the Buffalo Bills
and the Los Angeles Rams.
Yep, Buffalo versus L.A.
It was basically the wings
on your plate versus the celery.
You know what I'm saying?
I saw that the Buffalo Bills
have the best odds
to win the Super Bowl.
Yeah. Meanwhile,
the team with the worst odds are
the Houston Texans.
Yeah, they're not
supposed to be very good.
Check out the billboards
they're using to sell tickets.
This one says...
You see what I'm saying?
-That's the ad for the team.
-Yeah, this next one says...
I mean, that's cool.
I love Patrick Mahomes.
Finally, it says...
-Oh!
-Now, that's -- I would do it.
I'd do it.
♪♪
But, you guys, everyone's
excited that the NFL is back,
and there's no better way
to celebrate
than with some
football banner fails.
Hit it!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can't beat it.
Well, every year, guys,
the NFL introduces new rules
that they're going to enforce
in the upcoming season.
And we actually got our hands on
some of the updated penalties,
and there's some
pretty interesting ones.
Here, take a look.
This first penalty is for...
This next one is for...
And, finally,
there's a penalty for...
It's like, "'Dragon'?
"Lord of the..."
Speaking of,
did you guys see this?
In the most recent episode of
"House of the Dragon,"
fans noticed that HBO forgot to
cut out the green-screen glove
on a character who is supposed
to be missing two fingers.
Check this out. Look at this.
See if you can see. See it?
Yeah.
-Whoa!
-Yeah.
People are upset.
They want their show about
children riding dragons
to be 100% realistic.
Meanwhile, the CGI guy is like,
"Yeah, sorry about
those two teeny fingers.
I've been pretty busy, you know,
with the dragons
fighting each other!
I haven't seen
my kids in years."
Worried about the fingers?
I got a finger for you."
No. Hey, hey.
Watch -- hey.
-Hey!
-Watch it.
-One of the Finger Lakes.
-Guys, get this.
Today, former
Trump adviser Steve Bannon
turned himself in to
New York authorities
over an alleged
border-wall scheme
and was charged with conspiracy,
fraud, and money laundering.
Yeah. Can we see
Steve Bannon again?
I'll be honest.
Based on that photo,
I don't think he's ever
laundered anything.
-Hey! Hey!
-When the judge asked Bannon how
he pleads, he said, "Grimy."
Yeah, Steve looked unkempt,
as usual.
The judge was like,
"Please approach the bench.
Eh, that's close enough."
Hey, guys, I read that the FDA
just approved
the new anti-wrinkle treatment
called Daxxify
that could be
Botox's biggest competitor.
Yeah, right now,
the C.E.O. of Botox
is trying so hard to frown.
[ Cheers and applause ]
If you're keeping track, there's
Botox, Daxxify,
and a third one that doesn't
work from Johnson & Johnson.
Guys, I heard
that Merriam-Webster
just added 370 new words
and terms to the dictionary,
including "sus," "yeet,"
and "metaverse."
Yeah, it's a move that the
Oxford dictionary
defines as "desperate."
Yeah.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show,"
everybody.
Thank you all for watching.
We got some sad news today.
We learned that
Queen Elizabeth II
passed away at the age of 96.
And as a talk-show host, you
often get asked the question,
"Who would be your dream guest?"
And my answer
was always the queen.
I've always been a fan.
I've admired the way
she conducted herself
always with
class, grace, and dignity.
But, also,
she had a great sense of humor.
She was very funny,
and I loved that about her.
She leaves behind
a great legacy,
and she'll be missed
but not forgotten.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on, back.